lemon was on Colbert and listen to what
he says about CNN and try not to fall
out of your seat and if you're drinking
something watch out for the spit take
word on the street is that you guys
aren't allowed to be liberal anymore is
that is that the case I don't think we
ever were liberal what yes I don't think
we ever not me saying that that's the
people out there saying that he's not
letting you be liberal anymore I think
what Chris is
saying is that he wants Republicans
sensible Republicans he wants us to hold
people to account but he wants people to
come on and feel comfortable with coming
on and talking on on CNN and appearing
on CNN so if you invite someone in your
house you want to make them comfortable
but also but by the nature of what we do
we have to hold people to account and so
that doesn't necessarily mean that we're
going liberal or conservative or
whatever it just means that we are doing
what we do and that's good journalism
he's such a shell of nothing with thick
room glasses like it's just nothing what
he's saying there